[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
euphoria season two episode five if i
was to give this episode a title i would
call it the intervention from hell and
what's fascinating about euphoria season
two in general is it feels at times like
a completely different show and it's a
different show that i'm here for like i
think that this feels like a direct
continuation in the same vibe that
episode one of the season did where it's
almost like you're forgetting this was a
show set in a high school with high
school drama that it feels like you're
watching ozark or you're watching
breaking bad there's a lot of
similarities here and we'll get into
that as i go through this review but
first off we know zendaya has won an
emmy for euphoria season one can she do
it again well if the people behind the
publicity team are smart they should
obviously submit this as the emmy
submission for zendaya to have a repeat
title here because her performance in
this episode is incredible it's
incredible because i've been around
people in this state that she's in this
episode in similar situations and it's
completely accurate it's so honest and
such a natural performance that it just
seems like it comes so easy to her and
she's giving 150
but that doesn't downplay how great the
people around here are in particular
amazing acting by her mother this
episode played by nika king and as
always by gia played by storm reed
they're both incredible here as well and
i think they all need some kind of
recognition for this episode and that
includes the director here sam levinson
for what they pulled off in this episode
and why i'm saying it feels like an
ozark or breaking bad is those shows
feel very in reality they're very you
know they have that drama that's very
real so this to me reminded me of that
same tension and that disturbing feeling
that maybe someone you want to turn this
off because it's too close to home that
breaking bad in the episode of ozzie
mandus without spoiling that show but
it's that same feeling spoiler alert for
breaking bad you haven't watched it
leave now but it's that feeling when he
comes back home you know and that truth
is out now and it's that disturbing
feeling you can relate to and that kind
of you feel that fully here with rue's
story so we get a couple twists just in
this opening sequence here where this
intervention's beginning but you don't
really know it's a full intervention yet
that there's other people involved
besides her family and that comes with
the line where roo's like just drug test
me then she says to her mom and her
mom's like i don't need to jules told me
everything this was a whoa moment and
there's a big line where she says to rue
you're not a good person roo which isn't
the best thing to say in this situation
obviously that's a big hiccup and
probably a character fault in the
character of rue's mom and it's complete
opposite is a nice tie-in to last
episode where roo's having this moment
thinking of her dad saying she's a good
person to hear that not the best thing
for her state of mind but i love some of
the writing here when roo's like you
wish i was different so do i you effing
hate me so do i it's a very dark line
but a very truthful line and she's
saying this while she's panicking
looking for the suitcase because hey she
knows she's about to go into withdrawal
she needs her drugs b she also knows
what's going on with this character of
lori and what can happen if she doesn't
get this woman her money and i love how
they presented another twist that she
goes to her mom what did you do with the
pills and jules answers from the other
room we flushed him down the toilet the
way hunter schaefer delivered that line
was excellent and it's just a big moment
because okay jules is here this is an
intervention elliot's here and it's also
completely embarrassing obviously for
rue now and it's something that needs to
happen for a row this is a big wake up
call like interventions are and rue goes
in on jules here calling her a rat
saying you're dead to me and that i have
a lot of regrets in my life but meaning
you have to be the top of my list your
vampire sucking life out of everyone all
about jewels you like being loved
there's some truth to that about jules
but this is brutal by rue and jules
clearly did the right thing here as did
elliott believe it or not and you know
that's what they're gonna call them
though a snitch or at but this is out of
love by jules and jules does the right
thing here by just saying i love you
back to her and taking all this crap
from row but just knowing the state of
mind rue is in but this is the problem
where rue says you left me when i needed
you at my lowest this is classic murder
syndrome that drug addicts will display
and it goes into the guilt that jules
had felt a lot in season one that this
pressure that if she's not there for her
that was gonna relapse and this kind of
hits that and it's a brutal thing for
rue to say and it's obviously something
that really hurts jules hearing that and
elliot's a fascinating character me i
like that he's more fresh on the take of
a druggie where you know he's like i
liked her the way she was rue feeling
now bad about even telling jules
anything but he has a conscience you
know he's not this just easy liar so i
like it's kind of it makes his character
more fascinating and we always kind of
see that character just being quiet
about everything but he he does have
kind of a soul here so i don't know how
jules and roe are just even going to be
you know even on good terms again unless
roux gets completely clean here and i
love how they represent this because
when rue's at her weakest here and now
kind of open up to her mom saying i miss
dad i miss him a lot i love the shot
from rue's perspective looking down the
hallway of jules just looking at her
just upset and leaving and there was
something haunting about that about you
know when will these two even be in the
same room again now rude thinks she's
going to the er but they're taking her
to rehab and what really stays with me
and is really hard to watch is when ruse
says lines in the back of the car like
if you didn't do this intervention i was
a month from killing myself so this is
where the shift of great acting comes to
storm reed who plays gia here because
watching her hear her sister in the
state is heartbreaking and this scene
just in the car ride to rehab was so
powerful because you know anyone
watching this we've all been one of the
people in this car whether it's the mom
the sister or roo and in those shoes and
how it doesn't get darker than this and
you feel for everyone in waze here and
now we see rue would rather leave and
run out of the car than go to rehab and
she almost gets hit by a car this first
time out of two times she's run through
traffic in this episode and this is also
where the withdrawals are starting to
creep in more and more in the symptoms
of it and because of that and feeling
this withdrawals she's really not
thinking straight through the episode
and she goes to lexi's and just already
doing just deplorable things like going
through lexi's mom's medicine cabinet
and then taking some of her jewelry and
but when she comes back downstairs her
mom shows up and it's intervention round
two here and she's like [ __ ] and it's
with all her friends this time now this
big moment here which was completely
shocking to me is when roo says i can't
get clean can't do that [ __ ] forever but
cassie you know they make a joke of it
but she actually says something pretty
smart to rue here where she's like you
don't have to just take it one day at a
time i actually think that was the right
thing to say to someone like ruin the
situation i thought cassie meant well
and rue does just a horrible thing by
being completely hypocritical calling
jules and elliot snitches this episode
but she totally rats out cassie here to
maddie to get the attention off of rue
and it gets rue to be able to exit and
leave the situation it's such a selfish
thing and wrong way of doing it
especially because cassie was saying
something i thought nice and she says
how long have you been effing nate
jacobs and it just to me is like if
maddie wasn't in cassie's house with her
mom there and other people there you
know any other place maddie probably
would have like killed cassie so that's
going to be a huge turning point for the
season this information is now in
maddie's head about cassie where will
this go it's very interesting so i'm
happy they didn't drag out stories like
this and this was found out halfway
through the season it's the perfect time
to kind of keep the story going and
momentum and it makes you like excited
for next week like oh god like how does
next week even start like what is it
going to be like with maddie now and
cassie it's it's fascinating and nate
too so roo escapes again and now she
runs to fez's house and does something
even worse where she literally goes into
his sick grandma's room and tries to
take her medicine which is awful and fez
does the right thing here like no that
that's not happening and brutally roo
slams him into the wall just violent
it's just bad it's bad roo she's in this
crazy withdrawal state you know she's
literally gonna [ __ ] herself and i love
the line fez even had in this moment
where he's like you want some
pepto-bismol or something it's just
great like fez really is one of the most
likable characters now a hiccup in this
episode for me was i did think the
sequence of rue robbing this random
stranger's house to have more stuff to
give lori later on was unnecessary
because i think maybe just have her get
more stuff at lexi's or fezz's place
because i just thought that sequence
kind of killed a little bit of the flow
and kind of was a little redundant where
if you look back at episodes as a whole
it wasn't really necessary i don't think
so it felt like a little bit of padding
so i wish they kind of cut that scene
now they show a quick little scene i
thought was very important was when the
mom and g are now driving around the
neighborhood looking for rue and the
mom's like gia can you pay attention to
help me find your sister and she's just
on her cell phone texting this kind of
scene speaks volumes it's so short but
it's showing you that gia the sister
who's always been caring about rue is
starting to go the next area where this
relationship can happen where gia is
gonna start having less and less
sympathy for rue the more she has these
kind of episodes and that she's starting
not to care and feel anger towards her
now we see rue in her withdrawals barfs
in front of the cops
and it's our second barf you know in two
weeks
and like i'm saying it really feels like
a different show here and in a good way
i'm here for like her running from the
cops it's pretty intense and i thought
it was actually a nice comedic moment
where she fell into the cacti plural
cactus and you see the cops also fall
into the cacti i thought that was great
and these cops are literally like as
confident as the cops from super bad but
even little character moments are huge
here where again where she's running
through traffic this time almost gets
killed but she says please god don't let
me die so it's showing you yes there is
deep down through all of this suffering
of rude there's still this little will
to live now this is where the episode
really shines and it's so strong i don't
know if i like the first scene the
bestest episode or this last sequence
here with lori because laurie is
developing herself as this classic
villain now to me it's like a mix of
angela kinsey who plays angela from the
office with gus fring from breaking bad
she's so nonchalant about everything and
it's just exciting to watch and i love
the liner she's like i don't think i've
ever gotten angry in my entire life well
i don't know if that's true is that true
she's like yeah that's true like really
fascinating and it's like humorous to
watch her but it's terrifying and she's
seen you know rue going through
withdrawal hell and she's saying how
awful that situation is but she's like
you know you don't look like someone's
going to come with money any time soon
so we know there you know as much as
she's saying oh poor uru she still wants
her part of the deal wants her money and
it's really some heavy stuff and sad
stuff hearing her talk about opioids and
how it burns parts of the brain that
make you happy out it's like someone
having a brain who had a major stroke so
you know it's really heavy stuff and
anyone who's claimed that this show
glorifies drug use this is the episode
you'd show that person and say no it's
actually showing you how awful drug use
is what it can do to you and it also
shows the people you're losing and the
people then you start being around you
like these strangers that are just not
good everyone had to get chills down
their spine when she says lion one of
the good parts of being a woman even if
you don't have money you still got
something people want you're like oh no
because we know her threat was like yeah
okay you know you can't get my money
i'll get that money by selling you off
to somebody which is just terrifying and
i love all the parrots they got going on
in this building and i love a choice
that levinson made as a director here
where when roo is in the bath and
laurie's going over to her that it puts
in focus the morphine and not them and
that they stay out of focus and it's
just showing you that power that drug
has overruined the situation that that
even is the main driving force of all of
this and she's like i just want to die
i'll take anything you have and again
lori just so nonchalant about like okay
you know here's this morphine that she's
gonna inject into her which is not good
for rue it's another insanely addictive
drug and that creepy line you know
what's funnyroo when i first saw you i
thought this girl is gonna be in my life
for a long time just horrifying and what
brings that sympathy for us for real
seeing her all this stuff is again
seeing worse people around her but also
seeing roo dreaming about her dad at
this wake when she made this speech and
cut between her seeing gia for the first
time with her dad and also seeing baby
roo in the hot tub you know it brings
that humanity back and what's really
been on her mind and what causes her to
suffer and it hits well like that eerie
feeling of like her waking up in a room
she has no idea where she is in this
strange land strange world and there's
just this parrot here like just that
scary feeling maybe anyone's been in
where you're in just like somewhere
that's foreign to you and the insane
tension in the sequence of her trying to
get out and there's a parrot in there
and a guy with a gun really good stuff
it makes me like want to see sam
levinson just do a whole show in that
breaking bad ozark territory like why
not you know maybe not new euphoria but
maybe just a separate project down the
road because he's really good at it and
what's so impressive is you know it
comes all around full circle where this
episode started in the morning of a day
and ends in a full day here this whole
intervention that roo gets back home and
her mom was staying up all night waiting
for her really fascinating stuff and
really well done but even though she
gets away you know this is a big plot
line here that lori she still owes her
money you know lori is in the same town
okay like she's not going away she's
either going to get that 10k or she
wants roof to sell herself so it makes
you really excited i'm happy this
episode happened here that this is like
[ __ ] hits the fan episode and makes you
like oh my god like how does next week
even start and that's an exciting
feeling to have when you watch a show
like just wanting to see the first
couple minutes like what's gonna happen
with maddie and cassie what's gonna
happen with the roux and everything
that's just been put on the table here
it's really exciting this to me was the
best episode of euphoria yet i think
it's gonna be divisive because it
doesn't really feel like the euphoria
might be used to from season one but it
feels like the highest rate episode by
fans and critics like episode one of
season two again it feels like a
continuation of like okay you know sam
livingston wants to do do a lot of
different things here he said that in
interviews about season two he wants to
not make it feel a lot like season one
he wants it fresh but i like where he's
going with it i like this show that's a
rue kind of escaping from these crazy
people like lori it's very interesting
to me and it's like a weird mishmash
because you still got this high school
drama you're interested with cassie and
maddie so it's fascinating it's
different i appreciate that but look i'm
here for this kind of show but i think
some people are really into the high
school stuff of it or kind of be like
what am i watching you know so yeah i
could see that argument for that but for
me i love it i'm giving it a 9.4 i think
it's great it was just well thought out
episode exciting with great performances
great music like usual and awesome
cinematography but let me know what you
thought did you think this is the best
episode before if there was a better one
let me know what you thought was a
better one maybe if you didn't even like
subs at all i'd love to hear your
thoughts do you like this direction it's
going in let me know i read every
comment try to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews before i'll
be doing every single episode this
season and if you really like what i do
here i appreciate you becoming a member
today it will help me do more videos for
you guys and interviews and reviews all
that stuff i do will help me do it more
i'd really appreciate a donation and
you'll get special perks as well and
please follow me at steve arley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time